well
you kind of briefly opened the door so
let's go there
when it comes to uh government
regulation of crypto
uh what's the best case scenario what's
the worst case scenario in terms of
uh you know as you've kind of mentioned
ethereum challenges the the the power
centers of the world
and how do you see the interplay between
government
governments and this new technology that
resists centralized power
best case and worst case the the best
case
is that um
blockchains continue to prosper and we
figure out scalability is so that
people can actually start doing things
on block
all you know all of the amazing use
cases that people have been talking
about instead of today where
a lot of the great stuff gets priced out
because you know transaction fees are at
five to ten dollars
and then we see a lot of different um
amazing applications happening on
blockchains you know it could be
like dao is creating new ways for people
to
inter interact and organize with each
other new ways for artists to get funded
and
just all sorts of these amazing things
there's just enough public
um public support and just enough people
that see
that you know look crypto is clearly
doing a lot of good things
and and you know there are definitely
areas where there's tensions
but in those areas where there's
tensions like there could be some kind
of
creative and interesting approaches that
get figured out right like
you know the concept of corporate taxes
for example right like
you know it does it it that would
disappear as a revenue stream if
theoretically corporations just all get
replaced by daos but
oh no like maybe there's some other
creative
way by which dao
like taos themselves can kind of be you
know have some kind of encoded
governance that ensures that they
have at least some of us some kind of
bias towards
serving the global public good and uh
you know maybe it does enough of the
daos can do enough of that that people
are happy with it and and
you know there are going to be things
that people are unhappy about there's
always going to be the people that
you know wants to surveil everyone but
if
on the the kind of effect of crypto from
just
empowering people is greater than that
and greater than that in a way that
people can just easily see
then you know that would be a good
scenario right and we'll just
like become incorpor kind of
incorporated and accepted the same way
as happened
with the internet um but the
the worst case scenario would of course
be just like
people like suddenly you know flipping
and going into moral panic mode and just
you know oh my god like this technology
is used by like you know
insert bad group of the day and then i
don't think governments have the ability
to
ban crypto to the extent of just
complete like preventing
blockchains from existing but they
definitely have the ability to really
marginalize it right
like if you just ban all exchanges i can
ban all links from the fiat ecosystem to
crypto
and you know you ban all kind of
mainstream employers from
accepting or paying in cryptocurrency
then like you could
you can successfully like turn it into a
like you know a fairly kind of niche
counterculture thing that
has much less impact than otherwise
would so that's
somewhere between the good scenario and
the bad scenario i'm obviously hoping
for the good
well that's interesting also the tension
between governments and
companies like if you have a bunch of
billionaires or a bunch of companies
like tesla investing in bitcoin
and then governments resisting that it's
interesting who wins out in that worst
case scenario
and almost when companies
and uh rich quote unquote respectable
people
embrace uh cryptocurrencies bitcoin
ethereum
so on even the dot coins uh it's
almost sends a signal to everybody else
that this is
this is a revolution that's here to stay
you